thanks to ting mobile for keeping legal
eagle in the air
in the waning days of the trump
presidency people are wondering if
president trump is going to exercise the
pardon power to pardon himself and his
family
well yeah probably goodnight everyone oh
you want to know if there are any limits
on the presidential pardon power or if
there's anything that can be done to
stop the president using the
pardon power for himself and potentially
co-conspirators well
the u.s constitution gives the president
the power to grant reprieves and pardons
for offenses against the united states
except in cases of
impeachment even pardon a turkey
drumstick
you are hereby pardoned but could
president trump pardon
this turkey could he pardon his family
in potential
co-conspirators could he step down and
have president mike pence pardon him
before he leaves office
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer for the president
the pardon power is kind of like a magic
eraser that sets aside punishment for
federal crimes but that doesn't mean
that there are no limits whatsoever to
the power to pardon
the text of article 2 section 2
establishes a few limitations to the
broad grant of pardon power
for example the pardon power does not
apply to state crimes why
because the constitution explicitly says
that the president may only give pardons
to offenses against the united states
and that means
federal crimes people often mistakenly
believe a president can pardon or
commute the sentences of people
convicted of state crimes but that can't
be done
people with state convictions have to
look to their governors for reprieve
the pardon power also cannot be used to
set aside impeachment
there is some disagreement about what
this really means but at a minimum the
president cannot pardon an executive or
judicial officer
from an impeachment conviction in all
likelihood if president trump had been
convicted in the senate
he could not have pardoned himself in
order to remain in office and depending
on how the conviction was stylized by
the senate and the particular punishment
that was given
the conviction would have immediately
removed the presidential power anyway
but there's still some ambiguity about
the phrase in cases of impeachment as a
limit on
presidential pardon power especially if
a president pardons people who helped
him commit
impeachable offenses some people believe
that the constitution imposes other
limits on the pardon power
they generally point to the president's
article ii duties to faithfully execute
the laws
when a president takes the oath of
office he or she must affirm their
commitment to the rule of law
so we could argue that a president who
pardons himself his co-conspirators or
accepts favors in exchange for pardons
is not
faithfully executing the laws or the
duties of the office as a whole
these arguments certainly make sense but
they're completely untested and could be
completely unconstitutional the most
common response would probably be that
if a president is acting as if they're
above the law then the remedy
is impeachment and the founders wrote
at least one limitation into the pardon
power if they wanted to write more they
could have put in those limitations
directly into the document but let's
take a step back and talk about the
origins of pardon power and the pardon
power was adopted from an english
tradition known as the royal prerogative
of english kings
which gave the king the ability to
overturn any sentence it might seem
counterintuitive that the american
founders adopted the pardon since they
had just revolted against king george
iii because they thought he had too much
power and
james madison wrote that giving one
person legislative executive and
judicial powers was the very definition
of tyranny so why does the constitution
give the president the ability to
quickly reverse a court's judgment well
ask alexander hamilton who argued that
the pardon power was a tool a president
could use to
swiftly defuse tensions during times of
national crisis george washington
immediately used the pardon power to end
the whiskey rebellion and
giving the tax protesting farmers a
pardon rather than sentencing them to
death actually worked out pretty well
but hamilton trusted the pardon because
he thought it would be used only by the
most virtuous of men
but we are a long long way from george
washington now
but one of the issues that perennially
comes up especially in the context of a
potential
trump pardon is whether a pardon is an
admission of guilt
if someone accepts a pardon does he or
she admit that they were guilty of the
underlying crime
whether accepting a pardon is an
admission of guilt under the law is
actually an open question
in the 1800s after the civil war in ex
parte garland the supreme court said
that a pardon blots out the existence of
guilt
so that in the eyes of the law the
offender is as innocent as if he had
never committed the offense
this sentence suggests that a pardon
wipes away any person's guilt
yet the court seemed to back off this
interpretation in a 1915 case burdick
versus the united states
in burdick the court observed that a
confession of guilt may be implied in
the
acceptance of a pardon but verdict was
about whether a recipient could turn
down a pardon as some have argued the
court meant that as a practical matter
because pardons make people look guilty
a recipient might not want to accept one
but arguably pardons have no
formal legal effect of declaring guilt
in fact many people have been granted
pardons specifically because they're
innocent
there isn't much case law directly on
point but recent lower court cases
seem to align with burdick's statement
that a person admits guilt when they
accept a pardon
president george h.w bush pardoned
elliot abrams for his role in the
iran-contra scandal
but the dc bar initiated disciplinary
proceedings against abrams for lying to
congress during its investigation of
that scandal
abrams challenged the proceedings on the
grounds that the pardon not only erased
his criminal convictions
but it meant he couldn't be sanctioned
by the bar for lying under oath the
d.c circuit disagreed holding quote
because a pardon does not blot out guilt
one can conclude that
a pardon does not blot out probable
cause or guilt or expunge and indictment
so the pardon didn't force the dc bar to
treat abrams as lying under oath as
something that never happened
but could the president issue a pardon
that is so open-ended and broad that it
doesn't actually specify
who the recipient is could a president
issue a mass pardon to all people who
meet certain criteria
the answer to that is probably yes
there's no
limitation on broad pardons for example
andrew johnson pardoned all
ex-confederate soldiers in 1868.
benjamin harrison pardoned all members
of the mormon church who had committed
polygamy
and jimmy carter pardoned all who had
evaded the vietnam war in 1977.
so if historical precedent is any
indication if president trump wanted to
pardon let's say every person who had
ever been convicted
of a federal drug crime he could
probably do it he does not have to
specify each individual person by name
but by the same token he could probably
specify that anyone
involved in any crime related to the
quote russia hoax
could also receive a pardon and
effectively end investigations of that
which brings us to another one of the
perennial questions about pardons which
is
can a president grant a prospective
pardon where there's been no conviction
or even
indictment for a crime we expect
president trump to issue many pardons on
his way out of office
but can he pardon people who have yet to
be indicted or even investigated for a
federal crime
and the answer to that is a clear yes he
can do that it appears that a president
can issue a pardon
before any criminal proceeding against
that person has been initiated
this is a prospective pardon and in the
1866 case ex parte garland that we just
talked about
the supreme court announced that the
pardon power quote extends to every
offense known to the law and may be
exercised
at the time after its commission either
before legal proceedings are taken
or during the pendency or after
conviction and judgment
this basically means that the president
only needs to know a crime has been
committed he doesn't have to wait until
after the authorities indict or arrest a
person in order to grant them a pardon
the most famous prospective pardon is
when president gerald ford pardoned
richard nixon for
quote all offenses against the united
states which he
has committed or may have committed or
taken part in during the period from
january 20th 1969 through august 9
1974. nixon had not been indicted for
any crimes and resigned before he could
even be impeached
the pardon shielded him from any future
prosecution based on any criminal acts
he might have committed
during his time specified in the pardon
but that takes us to
a more insidious potential situation a
quid pro quo pardon
the phrase quid pro quo as you probably
now know is
something for something or give and take
so can a president dole out pardons to
people who offer him
gifts money or other things of value
well the law at 18 usc 201 makes it
illegal to bribe a public official
now it's an open question whether that
applies to the president but
putting that aside for the moment the
bribery statute doesn't necessarily make
a quid pro quo pardon
illegal in 2020 the house democrats
introduced legislation that would make
it illegal for a president to give a
pardon in exchange for something of
value
the same proposed legislation also made
it illegal for a president to pardon
himself
although it's sort of an open question
whether this law itself
would be constitutional the congress
can't pass a law
that conflicts with the constitution
itself interestingly
bill barr yes that bill bar is on record
as
saying that a president who sells a
pardon is guilty
of a crime a quid pro quo crime do you
believe a president could lawfully issue
a pardon
in exchange for the recipient's promise
to not incriminate him
no that would be a crime and he went on
to say that if a president
gave away a pardon in exchange for
someone's silence that could be
obstruction of justice well a quid pro
quo to change testimony could
potentially be obstruction
and that makes sense because there's
plenty of things that someone can do as
a governmental employee that you're
authorized to do but
under certain circumstances can be
illegal for example if your job is to
sell military equipment if you choose to
sell military equipment to north korea
well you're authorized to do it but it
can still be a crime
and selling a pardon as president is one
of those classic examples that you use
to say
that yes the president has that
authority but there are circumstances
that can give rise to illegality
now query what would happen under those
circumstances
in terms of whether the pardon would
still be in effect or not
these are things that would need to be
litigated and hopefully they'll never
need to be litigated
but the bottom line is that the most
likely remedy for a quid pro quo pardon
is probably impeachment not criminal
prosecution
and speaking of quid pro quo i was
checking my youtube stats and only 30
of this audience is subscribed to this
channel so if you're getting value the
quid
from this channel please subscribe and
hit the bell the quo and as the
president says
but first i'd like you to do me this
favor which takes us to the question of
whether the president can pardon his own
family
and the answer there is probably yes
there's no law or rule that says
president trump can't pardon his family
members
in 2001 former president bill clinton
pardoned his brother
roger who was convicted for cocaine
possession in arkansas
but there's nothing in the text of the
constitution or the case law surrounding
the pardon power that would seem like it
would limit president trump's ability to
pardon members of his family whether it
appears proper or not
but if you're talking about president
trump's family that's a natural segue to
the question of whether the president
can pardon his co-conspirators
president trump has been implicated in
many federal crimes it took place before
and after he took office we've done
several
videos about that in the past and in one
particular instance
president trump's former lawyer and
fixer michael cohen was sentenced to
three years in prison for several crimes
including
using campaign funds to pay off women
who had affairs with the president
federal judge william h pauley iii said
in open court that trump had directed
cohen to commit a federal felony
trump was referred to in this
proceedings as individual number one an
unindicted co-conspirator
and that's just one particular instance
there are lots of the president's
associates who have been implicated in
crimes that he was either involved in or
directed can the president pardon these
people
well it's certainly possible that
president trump will pardon people who
are considered his co-conspirators and i
hate to tell you but it's actually
happened before in 1987 an independent
council was investigating crimes
committed by members of the reagan
administration for
violating federal law by selling weapons
to iran and then illegally funneling the
money to contras in nicaragua for 18
months now we have had underway a secret
diplomatic
initiative to iran for all you kids out
there this was the iran contra scandal
attorney general william barr yes that
bill barr
helped president george h.w bush stop
this investigation by pardoning six
people including former defense
secretary kasper weinberger
who was about to go on trial to face
charges about lying to congress
so you can chalk this one up to the
pardon power being very very broad
there's
probably nothing that would stop the
president from pardoning people who have
committed crimes
at the president's own behest and of
course the first but
not the last lame duck pardon has been
given to former general michael flynn
in an insanely broad pardon i've covered
the michael flynn situation in the past
in a different video
you can check that out but many people
are outraged by the flynn pardon and
what arguably makes this different from
some of president trump's other pardons
is that the
criminal conduct lying to the fbi was
arguably designed to protect president
trump himself from prosecution or
impeachment
so here we have trump pardoning a person
who may have helped
him hide his criminal conduct does this
actually
matter though when it comes to assessing
the legality of the flynn barton
probably not although law professors
like mark osler have said the flynn
pardon is a despicable use of an awesome
power
even he agrees that this is part of the
broad expression of the pardon power
presidents enjoy
to be clear this is bad news for
democracy if a president can use pardons
the way a mafia
don would wield them as a carrot to
ensure loyalty from the dawn soldiers
but if you have a problem with it amend
the constitution
no seriously amend the constitution
president trump could pardon jared
kushner's dad
steve bannon paul manafort and even rudy
giuliani who's allegedly being
investigated for breaking lobbying laws
but does congress just have to sit back
and take it can congress investigate the
use of a pardon
although congress probably lacks direct
legislative authority to
limit the pardon power via federal
statute it does have other
constitutional tools for regulating and
overseeing the president's pardon
authority
congress has the right to use its
oversight powers to investigate they can
issue subpoenas and hold hearings on the
matters of presidential pardons
admittedly it's sort of an open question
in this era just how
powerful congressional subpoenas are and
whether congress has the ability to
enforce those subpoenas against
the executive but i suspect that out of
the wash
the courts will affirm congress's
ability to enforce subpoenas into
matters like these
and when president bill clinton pardoned
about 450 people at the end of his
second term
republicans in congress were outraged
and many of these pardons were
controversial such as his pardon of
democratic party donor mark rich
who had fled the country because of tax
evasion charges but congressional
committees held oversight hearings to
assess whether these pardons were for
lack of a better word
bad but the bottom line was that even if
the pardons looked bad or rewarded
people who had connections to president
clinton
congress lacked the authority to do
anything about whatever it uncovered
although presidents have complied with
subpoenas and witnesses have testified
the department of justice has said that
such compliance was voluntary and could
not necessarily be
compelled by a court it would certainly
be an interesting test case for the
supreme court which has expressed some
skepticism about the scope of how
subpoenas into president trump's
financial records but
it seems like it has to be the case that
if the remedy for
improper use of a pardon is impeachment
then congress has to have the ability to
investigate
the use of those pardons but that takes
us to the
penultimate issue with respect to
pardons which is what would happen
if president trump stepped down and
allowed mike pence to pardon him
many people wonder if donald trump could
resign at 11 59
a.m on january the 20th making mike
pence the president for
just a few minutes just long enough to
pardon president trump
yes this is a scenario that led to
gerald ford's pardon of richard nixon
for
years people have claimed that nixon and
ford made a deal that nixon would resign
if
ford agreed to pardon him this sounds
like a
sleazy deal but there doesn't seem to be
any evidence of wrongdoing or shady
dealing by ford
but at the end of the day trump could
effectively do the same thing instead of
leaving office two years before his term
is up as richard nixon did
trump could effectively step down with
just a few minutes left in his
presidency turn it over to mike pence
and ask for a pardon from president mike
pence of course president trump has
already stated that he could pardon
himself so he doesn't actually need to
do that
but the question is can the president
actually pardon himself
president trump certainly thinks he has
that power he said on more than one
occasion i have the absolute right to
pardon myself
but it's an open question because
obviously no one has ever done this
before so it's uncharted territory
and as with most things with
constitutional law first we look to the
text
of the constitution and as we've
discussed the constitution
gives the president the power to grant
reprieves and pardon for offenses
against the united states
except in cases of impeachment so at
first blush
it doesn't contain a limitation that
says unless you are the president
of the united states but that's not
necessarily the end of the question in
particular because
i think a lot of people consider the
idea of a president pardoning him or
herself to be
so odious another prudential argument is
that if the president could pardon
himself
he would forever be above the law many
believe that a sitting president
cannot be indicted if the president
could pardon himself before he leaves
office he'd be immune from all federal
crimes while in office and then forever
when he leaves
and in at least one part of the
constitution the framers clearly
intended criminal penalties after office
article 1 section 3 declares judgment in
cases of impeachment shall not extend
further than to removal from office and
disqualification to hold and enjoy any
office of honor trust or profit on the
united states
but the party convicted shall
nevertheless be liable and subject to
indictment trial
judgment and punishment according to law
many argue that the constitution says
that the congress may not impose
criminal penalties on a president
but the president is still nonetheless
subject to federal criminal prosecution
through ordinary courts and allowing
self-pardon would eviscerate that clause
of the constitution
and one of the canons of construction
the rule against surplusage
would lend credence to the idea that a
self-dealing pardon is void
other strictexulus argue that the plain
meaning of the pardon clause doesn't
actually allow for a self-healing pardon
specifically because of the word grant
as it's used in that clause
the constitution says the president
shall have power to grant reprieves and
pardons for offenses against the united
states
the grant of a pardon implies the
transferring of one thing to another
the constitution uses the word grant
five other times always in the context
of one person or body granting
something to another person or body for
example article one says
the legislative power herein granted
shall be vested in the congress of the
united states
here the people of the united states are
granting congress the right to make laws
also article 1 says congress may grant
letters of mark
and reprisal this means congress can
give private ships the right to start
wars against ships of other nations
this was an important grant of power
back in the day since it protected
private vessels against accusations of
piracy
notice again that congress is
transferring a thing letters of mark and
reprisal
to another entity it seems to imply two
people or at least
a separate grantor and grantee kind of
like a kidney donor you can have the
power to give a kidney but you can't
give it to yourself
legal eagerly speaking that's not a good
idea but i'm skeptical of this argument
for one
regular people and lawyers do use grant
in
a reflexive way for example in property
law a person might grant him or herself
an easement or
a life estate a life estate is a
property that an individual owns
only through the duration of their
lifetime you don't see life estates all
that often but i assure you they do
exist and law students hate them because
they make property law
really complicated and annoying but the
point is you can grant yourself a life
estate so it's not clear
which way this argument would go which
is one of the reasons why
the office of legal counsel of the white
house
has opined on this particular issue
several times
and there's a general principle in u.s
law that a person cannot be the judge
in their own case which would
argue against the president being able
to pardon him or herself
and in 1974 when president nixon asked
the office
of legal counsel the olc to determine if
he could pardon himself
the olc relied on that principle in
saying that president nixon could not
pardon himself and
in the famous august 5th 1974 memo of
the olc
mary lawton the acting assistant
attorney general wrote quote
under the fundamental rule that no one
may be the judge in their own case the
president cannot pardon himself
and four days later nixon resigned in
disgrace
possibly because he didn't think that he
was legally allowed to pardon himself
so given the president nixon's staff
opined that he could not pardon himself
and
often people complain the olc is really
beholden to the presidency and
aren't really giving objective opinions
and even
nixon himself would not go so far to
issue a self-pardon
that's potentially persuasive authority
that the president doesn't have the
power to self-pardon
and there is some authority from the
supreme court that's persuasive because
the supreme court hasn't
ruled on this precise issue of the
president pardoning himself
so it's not dispositive but it might
help in this analysis
there's really only one supreme court
case that's on point and that is the ex
parte garland case from 1866 which
we've talked about now twice in this
same video because there aren't that
many cases
and the ex parte garland case concerned
congress's ability to exclude members of
the confederacy from
practicing federal law after the civil
war and
whether the president could pardon a
confederate soldier
again going back to the idea of whether
the pardon expunges
everything or whether there's some
remaining residue from
the prior crimes that have been
committed and the supreme court held
five to four that the president could
pardon the confederate senator but
more importantly the court held
unanimously that the supreme court has
the authority to interpret the scope
of the pardon power and like the bedrock
supreme court case of marbury versus
madison
ex parte garland is probably less
important for the actual
outcome of the case then for the
principle the supreme court has the
overview authority to interpret the
constitution in this case and
make a decision one way or the other
about the president's pardon power
so this probably means that if president
trump tried to pardon himself he could
do it in the first instance he might be
able to file the paperwork for himself
but
under supreme court case law the supreme
court has the power to review that
pardon
and it's possible that the supreme court
could review the case
and actually nullify the president's
self-pardon on the grounds that
the president cannot be the judge in his
own case or that the impeachment
exception applies which prevents the
president's pardon from going into
effect
but the ex parte garland case was 150
years ago so
there's no telling that the current
supreme court is actually even going to
take up the case but the way that you
would test it is if
a certain president pardoned himself and
then
a new president whether a prosecutor or
the attorney general himself
decided to indict and move forward with
charging that president with a crime
well that former president would then be
able to challenge the prosecution on the
grounds that
he had received and granted his own
pardon and that would certainly go all
the way up to the supreme
court almost guaranteed it's possible
that if a case did make its way
up to the supreme court and query who
even has standing to bring
this uh challenge to the president's
self-pardon
that the court would look at and say
look this is a political question we've
seen the
modern supreme court punt on a lot of
questions claiming this is a political
question
left for the legislative and executive
branches and
the separation of powers and that
there's a remedy in the constitution
that
the president can be impeached and
removed even up to the last day
in office so if people find his
behavior so odious they can impeach him
and remove him from office and that is
the political
resolution to all of these things so
there's no telling what a supreme court
would do whether they would follow the
guidance of the
olc which is not binding precedent or
whether
they would allow the self-pardon to
stand
of course if president trump is indicted
he'll need to call a good lawyer from
jail
no i said a good lawyer well i guess
he's obviously going to have to make a
bunch of phone calls
and the best way to make those phone
calls is with ting mobile team mobile
has
three brand new plans you can get talk
and text for only ten dollars a month
data plans starting at fifteen dollars
five gigabytes for twenty five dollars
and unlimited for forty five dollars
switching plans is actually really easy
because you can keep your same phone
number and use pretty much any phone
and the service is great too because
ting partners with several massive
networks very possibly
the same one you're using right now but
at a huge discount
contractually i can't tell you which
ones because i always respect contracts
but i've mentioned them before and you
can almost see them over the horizon
so whether you use two gigabytes or 20
gigabytes a month there's a perfect ting
plan for you and your family
and if you're around wi-fi all the time
which most of us are considering we're
working from home
you have the flexibility to save
hundreds of dollars
i wonder if federal jails have wi-fi but
ting gives you the option to pay only
for what you use
because ting's flex plan gives you the
option to just pay for what you use it's
a smarter
cheaper version of the same plan that
they've always had now they're just
adding unlimited versions as well so if
you want unlimited data
go crazy so if you go to
legaleagle.ting.com you can use your
last bill to compare just how much you
would save
and legal eagles will also get a 25
credit that could cover
two months of service so just click on
the link in the description or go to
legaleagle.ting.com
and plus clicking on that link really
helps out this channel so
do you agree with my analysis leave your
objections in the comments and check out
this playlist over here with
all of my other real law reviews where i
talk about all the crazy stuff that's
happening in the waning days of the
trump presidency
so click on this playlist and i'll see
you in court